good afternoon everybody i wanted to
update you quickly on the latest covid
situation
there's no doubt that omicron continues
to surge with a speed unlike anything
we've seen before
situation remains extremely difficult
but i also recognize that people have
been waiting to hear whether their
christmas plans your christmas plans are
going to be affected
so what i can say tonight
is that naturally we can't rule out any
further measures after christmas and
we're going to keep a constant eye on
the data we'll do whatever it takes to
protect public health
but in view of the continuing
uncertainty about several things
severity of omicron uncertainty about
the hospitalization rate or the impact
of the vaccine rollout and the boosters
we don't
think
today that there is enough evidence to
justify any tougher measures before
christmas
and we continue to monitor omicron very
closely and if the situation
deteriorates we will be ready to take
action if needed what this means is that
people can go ahead with their christmas
plans
but the situation remains
finally balanced and i would urge
everyone to exercise caution
to keep protecting yourselves and your
loved ones especially the vulnerable and
remember to keep following the guidance
wear a mask indoors when required to do
so keep fresh air circulating and take a
test before you visit elderly or
vulnerable relatives
so if you have not done so already then
please
drop everything find a walk-in or go
online and make an appointment
and get boosted now
thank you very much and happy christmas